from bands on social media sites to
internet blackouts and harassment
campaigns against journalists
increasingly governments across the
continent are making it harder to speak
out last year there were more than 20
shutdowns across
a dozen countries in chat a block on
social media lasted over a year
now this year authorities in nigeria
congo and senegal
cut access to the internet during
elections and protests
now after blocking twitter nigeria says
social media companies
must be licensed by the broadcasting
commission
and in rwanda human rights organizations
warned that the repression
is more targeted more than 20 bloggers
and youtubers
have been detained or disappeared within
the past year
in our next report we meet one of those
journalists caught
in the crosshairs tionest sengimana and
his crew have come to this
overlooked corner of kigali to hear the
story of a community
seething with anger
residents here were promised
compensation to leave their homes
so a school could be built but the money
never materialized
such stories are common on singing a
successful youtube channel
it's not long before the police tell the
team to stop filming
a workplace hazard for rwandan reporters
last year he was arrested on trump top
charges
being a journalist in this country is
very hard you can get killed
you have to be ready to die of hunger
because you are deprived of work
and you're a candidate for prison at any
moment so you have to work like a
suicidal person if you want to advance
in this career
he is just one of a growing number of
youtubers who have been targeted by the
rwandan media regulator
they argue that memories of the 1994
genocide are a warning
that free speech can be used to incite
violence
i think we're right to tell journalists
to be careful we're still in a fragile
society
some of the content on youtube and on
the internet contains hate speech
and can be the cause of divisions and
even revisionism
[Music]
ngos say the crackdown on the youtube
community has gone too far
institutions are in charge of overseeing
the media have to look at critically
not to just block them or
end up throwing them in prison
or arbitrary or arrest them i think it's
something which calls for
an open dialogue looking at the
international standards
on media on from work speech and media
cengimana's team are editing their days
filming but their minds are back on what
they say is a government campaign to
crush free speech and dissent
the government must accept that people
need to share their opinions
to express themselves and the only
window left to be heard is youtube
so if they continue to lock us up with
their manipulated media propaganda
while people are suffering it will cause
problems in the future because the
citizens are frustrated
even as the threats of violence and
attention against journalists ramps up
singhi mana refuses to be silenced
from east africa we turn to west
africa's nigeria
where government's decision to forbid
access to twitter
has riled up users we are not in the
military regime we have
rights to freedom of speech and so we
should be allowed to speak
we shall we should be allowed to air our
views
whether be it on twitter facebook
wherever it is we should be allowed to
hear our views that's my
candid opinion there's other um social
media apps that are running currently in
the country
because i want to voice out our anger
let them know that what they do is so
wrong and
trying to let them understand that
whatever be that they are having in mind
that it's not for our own best interests
rather for their own sufficient
deeds the suspension came after twitter
deleted a post on president buhari's
account citing a violation of its rules
the ban was widely condemned but the
nigerian foreign minister defended the
move
during a meeting with diplomats uh
why we've taken this measure
is to see to what extent
we can re-balance
these media as forces of good
and stop them being used
as platforms for the stabilization for
more on this i am now joined by
jaffet omojowa he's a nigerian blogger
political commentator and social media
experts
hello jaffa welcome to the program so
you have one million followers on
twitter
what are your thoughts on the band
i think the band is embarrassing it's
very very avoidable the government
definitely has issues to grind with
freezer that they or they could have
like most most democracies around the
world
they should have engaged with directly
as a corporate rather than
removing their own citizens from those
platforms and causing jobs and
livelihoods
what do you think this means for free
speech
it's a huge setback for free speech not
just in nigeria but acne
for the continent because as you would
know nigeria has quite a huge social
and political and actually historical on
the continent so it's a huge setback of
free speech for liberty and all the
opportunities of freedom and liberty
in nigeria and in general on the
continent in africa
let's listen to the argument though the
government says twitter is a threat to
stability and peace in the country do
they have a point
i think they do have a point i actually
think they do have a point
with respect to the fact that twitter
has given platforms to people that are
directly calling on insurgency
that are directly coordinating
destruction and asking
and killings actually and so even though
they do have a point
the way they've gone about expressing
that point is what i have a problem with
they could have engaged twitter directly
and you know they could admit i
understand if you've given your
platforms to terrorists
in one way or the other and please find
a way to remove them from your platform
and that could have happened other
governments around the world have done
that and they've done that successfully
but the platforming your own people is
something that should have been
it's uncalled for and it was it was
something that they didn't have to have
tried or done okay so i think i see the
point you're making there you're saying
instead of totally banning the use of
twitter they should have engaged twitter
directly to
to try to address the situation very
challenging though but i see your point
this is not just a problem in nigeria as
you said earlier there's been dozens of
shutdowns across the continent
why do leaders like to target the
internet and social media
the first point of place for that is
because
lots of them are relics and they don't
understand how the world works now they
are coming from the age of
newspapers and television as the main
platforms for news
for news and people's access to news and
information the world has changed now
it's a much more democratized space
so whilst you can shut down a tv station
and nobody would even pay attention from
outside of your borders or even a
newspaper now
shutting down your people from accessing
the internet is a global issue even
though it's your old people
so they don't understand that this and
also there's always the side of
government
never comfortable with their people
having big voices too many voices
such a democratic space where anybody
can say anything
and minors even the power or uncover of
anonymity so it's something that
definitely would
make people that are used to power and
controlling everyone
get concerned and be afraid for their
own future with respect to their power
so oftentimes it's not even about the
country and the interests of the country
oftentimes about individuals and the
interests of this individual
it's an interesting point you're raising
on that point how concerned are you
or should we be that many countries seem
to be sliding towards a more
repressive approach
we should be concerned we should be
concerned and we should understand that
the battle and the quest for freedom
will never end look at america one of
the strongest democracies in the world
and they are too badly for the right to
vote and
the process of voting we hear about
pollution we hear about gerrymandering
and the likes and that's one of the most
one of the strongest democracies in the
world so we should be concerned i must
continue to commit to ensuring that
these spaces continue to be free
that liberty continues to be expressed
by everyone rich or poor
recoup recall or powerful irrespective
of their background and their race and
and all the opportunities of our
humanity so we should be concerned that
we must continue to commit to freedom
and our access to not just happens that
allow people to express their freedom
very quickly before you go what needs to
happen to ensure
freedom of speech on the one hand and
responsible use on the other
first of all is that everyone should
understand that whilst these platforms
are new
there are actually legal means to
addressing people that cross the line
when because of there's no freedom that
is absolute
i have freedom but i don't have the
freedom to kill no one i have freedom of
speech but i don't have the freedom to
ladder no one or defame no one
and there are laws against all of those
things so government must
just find a way to make those laws
stronger to accommodate
electronic evidence and evidence
according to the evolution of media
but there should never be a reason to
stop your people from speaking
because ultimately if your people do not
have the power to speak
then what's the essence of democracy
okay
jaffet nigerian blogger political
commentator and social media expert
thank you for your insights my pleasure
thank you